[Música]
los franceses votaron en la primera
ronda de las elecciones legislativas
primordiales para determinar si el
gobierno de manuel macro conserva la
mayoría en el parlamento las primeras
estimaciones de ipsos para france24
evidencia en un cabeza a cabeza entre la
coalición liderada por el manuel macrón
y sus opositores de izquierda tenemos
análisis
rusia dijo que destruyó un gran depósito
de armas estadounidenses y europeas en
la región de ternopil en el oeste de
ucrania en el este siguen los combates
en severodonezk donde se reporta la
destrucción por parte de los rusos de un
puente que conecta con la vecinalista
chang que dificulta la evacuación de
civiles
y este domingo se conmemora el día
internacional contra el trabajo infantil
según naciones unidas 1 de cada 10 niños
y niñas trabaja en el mundo lo que eleva
la cifra unos 260 millones un equipo de
france 24 fue a esta costa de márfil en
donde se estima que cientos de miles de
niños trabajan en plantaciones de cacao
bienvenidos a un nuevo resumen
informativo en france el 24 los acompaña
daniel hablando en francia cerraron en
las urnas en la primera de dos rondas
legislativas menos de dos meses después
de la reelección de manuel macro
enfrenta un fuerte desafío de un bloque
unido de izquierda que podría frenar su
agenda de programas sociales y
económicos
las más recientes proyecciones de ipsos
o sombra esterilla para france24 dicen
que hubo nueva unión popular económica y
social la coalición encabezada por el
partido francia insumisa de jean-luc
mélenchon los verdes y los socialistas
tendría entre 150 y 190 asientos en el
parlamento conformado por 577 curules y
en el que se necesitan 289 para tener
mayoría absoluta la coalición o juntos
de manuel macro ni sus aliados tendría
entre 255 y 295 sillas los partidos de
centroderecha por su parte encabezados
por el tradicional en los republicanos
obtendrían entre 50 y 80 asientos la
agrupación nacional de marine lepén de
extrema derecha tendría entre 20 y 45
y ya tenemos las primeras reacciones ma
jin lepén del partido de extrema derecha
agrupación nacional y quien se midió
también en la segunda vuelta
presidencial contra el reelecto
mandatario de manuel macrón invitó a
derrotar al oficialismo en la segunda
vuelta dimos por ya el próximo domingo
es importante no dejar que manuel macrón
tenga una mayoría de la que abusara para
impulsar su agenda auto céntrica y nos
imponga su proyecto antisocial para
hacer lo que quiera cuando quiera pero
sin ti y contra ti a otro plazo mesón te
subo con com también se pronunció jean
luc mélenchon el líder de francia en su
misa que pertenece a la coalición de
izquierda nueva unión popular económica
y social en nubes
por la polonia fue por primera vez en la
quinta república un presidente recién
elegido no ha logrado establecer una
mayoría en las elecciones legislativas
en curso al elecciones stojic hago un
llamado a nuestro pueblo para que
aproveche esta extraordinaria
oportunidad de votar en masa el próximo
domingo apple nuestro pueblo
advirtió le dimos porción y desde parís
nuestra corresponsal y natalia ruiz nos
entregó detalles más tempranos sobre
cuáles serían esas reformas que pretende
impulsar el presidente emmanuel macrón y
que estarían en juego dentro de esta
nueva legislatura
pues quizás la principal de esas
reformas es la reforma pensional y es
que va a ser digamos la
gran
digamos la gran reforma que él va a
tener que llevar a cabo que fue uno de
los puntos esenciales a lo largo de toda
esa batalla por las elecciones
presidenciales él ha hablado de pues de
la edad de pensión que debería pasar a
los 64 65 años y allí es donde hay
digamos una de las partes más
importantes de desacuerdo entre la
izquierda entre la derecha e incluso
entre las mismas derechas no están de
acuerdo en que esta edad en que esta
jubilación pues pase a los 65 años
actualmente es de 62 algunos partidos
también han pedido que pase de hecho a
los 60 años y se tenga en cuenta también
todo lo que tiene que ver alrededor de
la pena habilidad penny bilidad del
trabajo de aquellos cargos de aquellos
puestos de trabajo en donde pues hay
todo un desgaste físico que debe también
tenerse en cuenta así que esa es la
principal la reforma que él pues va a
llevar a cabo en todo caso ese es en
todo caso lo que busca es era uno de sus
puntos principales de su programa
presidencial pero efectivamente ahora
con estos resultados el día de hoy
esperar a lo que pueda suceder dentro de
ocho días podría complicarse mucho para
él en caso de que sea la izquierda a la
que se quede con una amplia mayoría en
la asamblea nacional
y para analizar el transcurso de esta
jornada legislativa también enlazamos en
parís con el analista político guillaume
a askari lo saludo primero y le pregunto
que se puede concluir señor askari de
esta elección y las primeras
estimaciones que se tienen
buenas tardes bueno primero creo que en
el dato ya clave de esa lección creo que
también es también la abstención también
con un
52,3 por ciento que representa bastante
bastante persona que no amigo que no sé
no han ido desde su casa hasta las
escuelas hasta las las municipalidades
para votar y ese es su forma una
histórica abstención pero esa esos
resultados también forma un común una
advertencia con por qué manuel macrón
por resolver la coalición juntos porque
son la comparación con 2017 son siete
puntos menos que en 2017 y la mayoría no
se da por ganado por hecho
bueno y
si le pregunto también cómo queda
entonces la izquierda y
los partidos los contradictores al
presidente de macrón yo si llegaran a
tener más curules en esta legislatura
que el anterior
bueno yo creo que sí por la primera vez
vimos una coalición que se formalizó con
el tiempo que en poco tiempo después de
hacer la dirección residencial y yo creo
que hay una posibilidad y por la
coalición
nubes de izquierda de poder devolverla a
la primera la principal el principal
grupo de oposición
en el parlamento francés pero ese es
también decir que el grupo de los
republicanos el partido los republicanos
de la derecha guiando también o sea
muestra a continuación de la elección
presidencial que no consiguió no logró
también aguardar o sea un nombre de
escaños que le permite también de tener
un grupo o un grupo de oposición
principal yo creo que es el mejor son en
todo eso en esa coalición va a tener más
más diputados en suecia por cierto que
en 2017 pero también va a formar también
un una voz de oposición muy grande y eso
es sólo que muestra entender los
resultados por esa primera huerta señor
guillén también se conocieron las
proyecciones iniciales de ipsos obra
seria para france 24 que dicen en qué
nueva unión popular económica y social
la coalición que decíamos está
encabezada por el partido francia
insumisa dejando como no son los verdes
y los socialistas pues habría obtenido
un 25,6 por ciento de la votación y
también que la coalición juntos de
manuel macro ni sus aliados habría
estado un poco por debajo con un 25,2
por ciento también vemos como la
agrupación nacional de my independent de
extrema derecha habría tenido un 19,1
por ciento y si vemos otros resultados
los partidos del centro-derecha
encabezados por el tradicional los
republicanos también habrían tenido un
13,6 por ciento
de preguntarle en ese sentido porque si
tienen un porcentaje parecido tanto
macro y su partido y sus aliados y sus
opositores porque si tienen esta misma
está misma participación las curules son
diferentes el estimado de curules
bueno porque primero es no es el
mismo votante que va a votar este macro
y israelís - o el día - ahora ha logrado
también a unir tanto el grupo de los
ecologistas tanto en parís que en otro
otras que llegan de otras provincias en
francia y eso pensó que le va a permitir
también de
decretarse a crecer al menos o sea unas
proposiciones unas propuestas que él
tiene en el parlamento desde desde unos
años como por ejemplo el rey por ejemplo
y es en ese grupo de
de esa agrupación de ese grupo de
personas de candidatos ya tienen tienen
una mayoría también por ejemplo tienen
temas más más convicciones por el
peligro la ecologista o sabes es bien
diferente o sea que el partido de él
el partido de de lerma con la coalición
señor scary también cómo quedan entonces
los ánimos de los partidos de cara a la
segunda vuelta según estas primeras
estimaciones
bueno yo creo que vamos vamos a tener un
parlamento que va a ser y vídeo que ya
hay un riesgo de cohabitación hay que
decirlo yo creo que vemos un hundimiento
de los partidos tradicionales desde
desde desde dos años desde también la
elección también presidencial y antes y
yo creo que hay un un riesgo más bien
también conectar esa unión esta nueva
unión popular y yo creo que hay nubes
hay que hay también posibilidades que al
final o sea haya una cohabitación o si
no una mayoría no absoluta pero corta
por el partido de la coalición juntos
y también finalmente pues cómo queda el
partido de extrema derecha de ma jin le
pen que según las estimaciones entonces
tendría un 18,9 por ciento de la
votación está más fortalecido o
debilitado frente a lo que tenemos en
este momento en el parlamento francés
está más fortalecido por supuesto yo
creo que
eso eso muestra también una progresión
del lado demande marie le pen que como
como mostró también este es en su
reportaje llamó también a a también a
mostrarse como a posicionarse más bien
como como una voz de oposición y yo creo
que en todas manera hay una progresión
por mariló pena en una progresión por
por la menor son por mariner tienen por
cierto porque bueno es desde todas esas
elecciones las pasadas legislativas no
tuvo esos esos resultados eso muestra
que también hay una dinámica después se
tendría que ver al momento de la segunda
vuelta de estas elecciones que sería el
resultado porque
todavía hay muchos muchos muchos
lugares en sitios donde en francia donde
no es seguro que marine le pen
tiene un diputados un escaño
pues señor guillaume a askari analista
político le agradecemos mucho por sus
comentarios en francés 24 hasta una
nueva próxima oportunidad
muchas gracias
cambiamos de informaciones feroces
combates continúan en la ciudad de
severodonezk las autoridades locales
ucranianas reportaron este domingo que
las fuerzas rusas destruyeron un puente
que comunica a la ciudad con su vecina
lysychansk lo que dificulta la posible
evacuación de civiles se reportan además
varios cientos de militares y civiles
que se encuentran dentro de la planta
química de azotó quien ha hecho un
pedido desesperado de armas a occidente
diciendo que rusia tiene al menos 10
veces más artillería
en medio de las explosiones
un soldado ucraniano detiene un auto y
ayuda a subir a una mujer vida aquí
lysychansk las fuerzas rusas y
ucranianas liberan una batalla de
artillería casas y vehículos estallaron
en llamas
las ciudades cerca severodonezk y el
objetivo actual del avance ruso aquí se
cree que hay cientos de personas
bloqueadas dentro de esta planta química
el sábado el gobernador regional dijo
que el bombardeo de la infraestructura
ha causado un incendio y una fuga de
aceite según los separatistas apoyados
por moscú 300 a 400 soldados ucranianos
están dentro mientras quiera afirma que
hay 800 personas incluyendo civiles
reinicia el ejército ucraniano y miembro
de los batallones nacionalistas siguen
en la zona industrial en la planta de
ashdod desde donde bombardean la ciudad
no podemos actuar fuertemente allí
porque es una infraestructura industrial
química futurista
chevron y us ilicic an son las últimas
zonas del este de la región de luhansk
que todavía están bajo control ucraniano
en el sur del país las fuerzas de moscú
que ocupan la ciudad de carson se vieron
distribuyendo pasaportes rusos a los
residentes una medida es desestimada por
el presidente de ucrania
con barranca entre los residentes había
colaboradores y gente del entorno ruso
no aparecía una fila para obtener
pasaporte sino más como una tentativa
para salir es muy revelador
gordimer selenski dijo que las fuerzas
ucranianas han empezado a reconquistar
partes de la región de carson y que
estaban ganando terreno en sa por día
y el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg dijo que son legítimas las
preocupaciones de seguridad planteadas
por turquía en su oposición a las
solicitudes de membresía de finlandia y
suecia a la alianza militar lo dijo al
visitar al presidente de finlandia saúl
y di nizó agregando que ningún otro
aliado de la otan había sufrido más
ataques terroristas que ankara y que por
lo tanto sus preocupaciones se debían
tomarse en serio el líder sin embargo
felicitó que tanto suecia como finlandia
quieran mantener conversaciones con los
turcos
en la decisión correcta para finlandia y
suecia solicita la membresía que
fortalecerá su seguridad y reforzará la
otan y reforzará la seguridad y la
estabilidad euroatlánticas
ping nos ha sorprendido en la posición
de turquía pero como en la política
internacional se deben tomar en serio
todas las razones que dice la
contraparte y eso es lo que vamos a
hacer tomarnos en serio lo que propone
turquía
y este domingo 12 de junio se celebra el
día mundial contra el trabajo infantil
una actividad que según la organización
internacional del trabajo desempeña en
unos 160 millones de niños y niñas en
costa de márfil en áfrica occidental-
más de 800.000 menores trabajan en las
plantaciones de cacao según un estudio
de la universidad de chicago realizado
en 2019 más de 2.000 de ellos han sido
retirados de los campos llevados a
centros y luego enviados a la escuela
aunque el tráfico y el trabajo de
menores continúan en el país situado a
300 kilómetros al oeste de abiyán la
región del agua es una de las mayores
zonas agrícolas de costa de marfil
también uno de los territorios más
afectados por el trabajo infantil
hoy sabin tiene 18 años nunca fue a la
escuela porque su abuela la cuidaba en
el campo pues que ganó cámara cuando
nuestros amigos iban a la escuela ella
quería que fuéramos pero no podía
permitírselo así que no tuvo más remedio
que enviarnos al campo al igual que xavi
el 90% de los casos de trabajo infantil
se producen en el seno de la familia
suelen suponer el abandono de la escuela
pero en este centro dedicado a la
acogida de niños víctimas de la trata o
del trabajo forzado también hay muchos
niños de países vecinos fatal un chico
de 15 años de burkina faso fue recogido
en un campo de cacao hace una semana
fatal o no es víctima del trabajo
forzado sino de la trata de personas
desde burkina una red organizada lo
llevó a costa de marfil
los burkineses los malienses cuando
tienen un hijo en costa de marfil para
ello eso es algo seguro así que todo el
mundo quiere tener un hijo aquí con un
producto como el cacao que atrae a todo
el mundo
arturo con el cacao representa el 14 por
ciento del producto interno bruto de
costa de marfil es la actividad más
afectada por el trabajo infantil en el
país por lo tanto es en las aldeas de
los plantadores donde tratan de
concientizar a los adultos esta brigada
contra el trabajo infantil viene a
reunirse con el jefe del pueblo para
transmitir un mensaje sencillo al
dirigirse a los líderes de la comunidad
la brigada espera a llegar a todo el
pueblo
flores pueden ser nuestros reemplazos el
jefe está ahí él también tiene reuniones
voy a hablar con los que pueden ser
reacios para mostrarles los beneficios
otro lugar según las últimas
estimaciones para 2019 15 millones de
menores trabajaban en el sector del
cacao en costa de marfil y ghana y
hablamos ahora del cob y de 19 que sigue
siendo una preocupación en china sólo el
sábado se registraron 122 nuevos casos
de contagio según las autoridades menos
de dos semanas después del levantamiento
del confinamiento en shanghai un tercio
de los habitantes de la ciudad tuvo que
quedarse en casa este fin de semana en
beijing también se registra un nuevo
brote epidémico y las autoridades
debieron posponer la reapertura de las
escuelas
otro test masivo para los habitantes de
shanghai tras nuevo brote epidémico 23
millones de personas deben ser
examinadas en pocos días a la espera de
los resultados 8 millones de personas
tuvieron que confirmarse este fin de
semana sólo 10 días después del
levantamiento de un confinamiento muy
duro de 2 meses esta decisión hace temer
a los residentes que se apresuraron a
hacer compras
y por supuesto estoy preocupado el
confinamiento se levantó el primero de
junio recuperamos poco a poco y
retomamos una apariencia de trabajo
normal
yo estoy un poco preocupado porque si
hay casos positivos en el barrio los con
fin harán también voy a almacenar
algunas provisiones para evitar una
situación similar a la que ocurrió
trivisión sesiones en contra fácil esta
nueva alerta afecta también la capital
china donde los restaurantes han
reabierto esta semana se detectó un
brote importante este sábado en un bar
muy popular
y el cluster epidémico a gran escala
ligado al bar parada y super market en
el barrio de chaoyang ha tomado un giro
feroz el trabajo de prevención y el
control de esta epidemia es más difícil
que el del mercado desinflado y el de la
última ola epidémica
la reapertura de las escuelas en la
capital china prevista para el lunes ha
sido pospuesta
y así llegamos al final de este resumen
informativo en francés 24 consulte estas
y otras informaciones en france 24 punto
com
[Música]